here's James against Ingram step-back
three is good really improved his
three-point shoot looking to push tempo
here the pelicans number five in the NBA
in fast-break points
favors no the sign is there with the
stick back slam screen by Williamson
look into role but Greene recovered now
the LOB from Lanza phulwa play by Sukup
see it's a little bit easier at the rim
until you meet your veil rejected by the
game James goes behind the back and then
reverse layup is good
James bodying Josh Hart too powerful for
LeBron up and under good and one to both
guys he's trying to play volleyball
initially josh is an excellent defensive
player but that's these are on pace the
pelicans are on pace for 80 points in
the paint
so the initial matchup and the help that
Frank was talking about is appropriate
and there he goes again
bring it look sit just a post-up very
quick footed bully ball with kyle Kuzma
help by the time dwight gets there
forget about it look at how fast he's up
and might anticipate the Lakers without
Anthony Davis in the help position could
give up more paint points tonight
obviously James going it's ion and
LeBron wins that one but let's just
watch LeBron I mean you know you know in
Gladiator where that guy says not yet
he's with one three-point attempt and he
made it it was from the right corner
there he finds the open man Caldwell
tall able to connect from three-point
range
Kyle kuzmic did was stay attached to his
body James is what they want to be under
Alvin Gentry Alonzo ball taken that
directive and going with it James
backing down ball here comes the double
LeBron makes the right play and Quinn
cook pays it off with a triple until
alone before informs ion of that and as
LeBron scores inside to give him 16
point he'll try a three no good
rebounded by James looking to run here
LeBron bounced past the cooze ball for
two
tremendous catch
[Applause]
eleven and a quarter Wow James from
about 20
I think the Zion dunk
maybe trigger that shot by James from
this in a spotlight in making the most
of it which then led to this that was
past 30 T Davis tonight out with a sword
knee the second game of back-to-back so
you will not face his former team make
that a tougher shot on Brandon Ingram
you thought he got separation that's
multiple effort by Cruz
balls perfected that with Williamson oh
no pressure on it he's just surveying
over pretty good the target to throw to
they do this all the time that spin off
that's dangerous does a teammate texting
he looked at LeBron and pointed in his
chest like my fault Sian Williams
this team attacks let's just watch the
combination of speed and power I mean
there's James guarded by heart LeBron 10
of 16 shooting 11 assists so far team
blows past Hart and James it dear said
than done
going right to the low post alright you
dig me out of there let me go back to
the basket spin off you good night
assists in nine rebounds no Anthony
Davis tonight holiday on the paint
Williams and his soars to the rim NBA
career
here's James back and down holiday all
the broth hurt his feelings that time
the night for James holiday to a puting
Williamson and SIA goes up strong Dwight
Howard like drew gets the rotation
Dwight is reacting but now you got to go
back and guard this guy and he goes
right through the chest of Dwight Howard
that's a guy 611 a future Hall of Famer
who has blocked James against Holliday
five to shoot fires to a wide-open Kuzma
and knocks it down discussion should be
a little closer everybody in the
building is aware LeBron is gonna find
the right now 13 triple doubles now for
LeBron James
tying Lucas on tich for the NBA Lane and
going up against Williamson
fires pizza pray father Zion who can
only smile he's half his age LeBron's
got a son that's only four years younger
than Zion and is if science and I'm kind
of enjoying this potahto affair ball
fouled on the putback try and look at
the intensity of LeBron James little jab
step back into a rhythm free money